في كل يوم تقريبا تمر بنا عبارات من نوع
هذا عبقري هذاك مجتهد هما الوصفان اللذاني
يرى في قانون الابداع دائما بالفعل لكن في
مشكله في الموضوع المشكله وفي نظر الناس
تحديدا هو على ما يبدو تحيز الناس للمبدع
او الموهوب الفطري على حساب الشخص المجتهد
وذلك بحسب دراسه نطرحها معكم اليوم لنفس
الموضوع طبعا
ونفسر هذا الموضوع اكثر الناس عاده يميلون
الى تقدير العبقري بالفتره اكثر من مجلهم
لتقدير الذي يتعب ويجتهد ليكون مبدعا
ومؤثرا
وفي هذا مشاهدينا ينسى الكثيرون ان النجاح
ي
اتي من مكملان لبعضهما بحسب الكثير من
المبدعين لا ننسى ان توماس اديسون احد
اشهر العلماء قال يوما بان العبقريه هي
واحد بالمئه الهام وتسعه وتسعين بالمئه
اجتهاد حبيت هذه المقوله بس في النهايه
مشاهدينا ابداع او اجتهاد المهم الانجاز
والنتيجه في النهايه والمهم اكثر انه نسمع
التفاصيل
شكرا لكما
اذا الناس يحترمون الموهوب اكثر من الشخص
المجتهد وهذا فسرناه قبل قليل بفكره
التحيز الطبيعي فما تفاصيله يقول علماء
النفس ان الوعي داخل الانسان يفضل الفطره
على تاسيس وهنا تبدا فكره تفضيل الموهبه
على الشخص المنجز المجد المنطقه التي
يعتبره البعض ظالما يقول ان الشخص الذي
يعمل بجد خالف طبيعته التي لا تؤهله
للابداع وبالتالي فان احترام انجازاتهم
مهما كانت لن يكون كبيرا وبحسب تجارب
العالمه على العقل البشري فانها تؤكد ان
التحيز الطبيعي قد يكون نتيجه معالجه
الدماغ غير الواعيه للواقع وبالتالي
التفضيل الغريزي للموهبه على الاجتهاد
المفاجئ في كل هذا انه بحسب مؤتمر الشخصيه
وعلم النفس الاجتماعي فان اكثر من 80% من
الناس يركزون على ذكر اجتهاداتهم على حساب
قدراتهم الفكريه تفسير ذلك ان الناس
يميلون لذكر الظهور بشكل متواضع بعيدا عن
الغطرسه على كل حال سالنا الناس في مصر
لماذا يقدر الناس الموهوب بالفطره اكثر من
العمل الجاد نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
الموهوب بالفطره ممكن يجيب لك الفكره من
بره الصندوق ممكن يجيب لك حاجه جديده
العمل الجاد ممكن اه هو بيشتغل بضميره كل
حاجه بس ممكن بيغلط او بيشتغل على الرولز
اللي هو شغال عليها انا بقدر العمل الجاد
اكتر
لان الواحد بيفزل مجهود وبيبقى عنده هدف
هو
[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس في السعوديه ايضا لماذا يقدر
الناس الموهبه الفطريه اكثر من العمل
الجاد ماذا قال
[موسيقى]
الموهوب عنده خيارات واجد ويرضي يعني يرضي
شريحه كبيره من الناس اما المجتهد يمشي
على منهج واحد والمنهج واحد قديم يرضي
يعني شريحه قليله من الناس يعني انا برايي
افضل الموهوب الشخص الموهوب يعني
سبحان الله الابدعت تجي من عنده لكن اللي
يشتغل على نفسه كل الاشياء اللي يسويها
تكون مكتسبه فهذه ميزه الموهوب عن الشخص
الثاني الموهوب يمكن يقدم اشياء جديده
ويخدم المجتمع اللي هو عايش فيه يعني
ويقدم اشياء جديده
على عكس اللي يشتغل على نفسه فمنه بيقدرون
الناس اكثر بس انا اقدر الشخص اللي يشتغل
على نفسه عشان يبغى ينتقل له حاجه اكثر
واعلى منها حاجه ذي يعني يتعب على نفسه
ويزيد عنده نشاطه الموهبه موجوده وقد تكون
سبب النجاح ولكن انا من الناس اليوم من
بالعمل الجاد والتخطيط لانه مثل ما يقول
الامريكان يعني اي شيء بسهوله يذهب بسهوله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا معنا الامن القاهره مدربه
التطوير والمهارات فاتن سلامه اهلا بك
فاتن معنا في صباح العربيه
فاتن يعني من الواضح بانه الناس معجبه
اكثر بالمواهب الفطريه والمواهب الطبيعيه
ولكن يعني انا من وجهه نظري على الاقل انه
طبعا اكيد يجب هي ثمينه ويجب ان تقدر ولكن
اللي مثير للاعجاب اكثر هو الانسان اللي
بيشتغل على حاله اكثر من الانسان اللي خلق
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى اعطاه هذه الموهبه
بدون ما يكون هو له يد فيها
هل ممكن العمل الجاد يعوض ولو حتى جزء من
الموهبه
صباح الخير راويه وصباح الخير عادل وعوده
حميدا والحمد لله على سلامتكم وصوركم على
الشاشه من جديد في صباح العربيه وطبعا
فكره الموهبه والعمل الجد ودائما يعني حتى
الاختلاف ده وصل البيزنس او لاداره
الشركات وبقى عندهم اداره في الشركات تسمى
اداره المهارات رجوعا لسؤالك يا راويه
وكمان من اراء الناس في شارع وما اتفق
عليه ان الموهبه بلا عمل جاد لن توصل الى
النجاح النجاح بدون موهبه في حد ذاته هو
موهبه العمل الجدي والوصول الى هدف معين
في حد ذاته هو موهبه ولكن لماذا يقدر او
يحترم الاشخاص الشخص ذو الموهبه الفطريه
اكثر من الشخص الذي يجتهد ويعمل هم هيحترم
وهيقدروا اللي بيجتهد ويعمل عندما يصل
يعني هم مش هيبصوا لكفاحه مش هيبصوا لما
يعانيه في رحلته ولكن هيبصوا للنهايه
هيتخيلوا ان هو اه خلاص ده عمل ده بموهبه
الموهبه زي ما حضرتك ما تفضلتي وقلتي ان
هي المنحه اللي ربنا سبحانه وتعالى مديها
للشخص عشان يعمل شيء معين بدون مجهود عضلي
او ذهني ولكن بيعملوا بابداع طب ماذا لو
هو عنده هذه الموهبه ولكن ما عملش
فبالتالي هتبقى الموهبه لا قيمه له
يعني فكره الانحياز الطبيعي اللي يعني
الموهبه بدون عمل جاد لا تنفع كما تقولي
ولكن العمل الجاد بدون موهبه ممكن
وسيوصل الانسان الى النجاح
طبعا طبعا
عادل بدا بمقوله اديسون انا هزيد عليها
مقوله اينشتاين عبقريه اينشتاين على حد
قوله ليست فقط من الفطره اللي عنده او
ليست فقط من الموهبه الفطريه اللي عنده
ولكن لبذله وقت طويل جدا لحل المشاكل يعني
هو بيجتهد حتى يصبح او اجتهد ليصبح
اينشتاين خليني اخذ انا الدور الاخر من
يقول بانه لا الموهبه الفطريه هي الاساس
وبالتالي من هو موهوب فطريا مثلا في
الموسيقى راح يعطيني مقامات وانغام تختلف
عما هو يسعى ويحسبها بعمليه حسابيه او
بتطوير ادوات هذه تاتي تلقائيه وتصل الى
القلب اكثر الناس بتحب الموهوب فطريا ميسي
ورونالدو
برضو عنده
عنده جمهور يعني انا وراويه
لا تفتحين علي النبض فاتن
بنحب ميسي كمان احنا بنحب كمان ميسي ولكن
عادل فكره الفنون التمثيل الموسيقى الرسم
الكتابه كل دي مواهب ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
بيكون مديه للانسان هل لو احنا الاتنين
انا وانت عندنا نفس الموهبه ولكن انا ما
اجتهدتش ان انا ابتكر شيء جديد لو لو ما
اجتهدتش ان انا اتعلم شيء جديد وخصوصا مع
طفره الارتباشه او الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي
موجود حوالينا والتكنولوجيا اللي كل يوم
بتطلع لنا بترند جديد تفتكر هيكون في
كونسيستنس او استمراريه في نجاحي او نجاحك
الشخص الذي يعمل على نفسه
ويثقل موهبته بمجهود وعمل وان هو يواكب
التطور هو من سوف يستمر
بصقل هذه الموهبه فاتن لكن
التلقائيه اقصد ايضا هي حتى مثلا بالفن
لما نقول الافيه يطلع من من الموهوب غير
لما يكون الافه مكتوب
صح ولكن كان من الكوميديانات اللي عندنا
في عالمنا العربي ما بيشتغلش يعني دي حاجه
دي حاجه تانيه دي حاجه يعني مع الموهبه هو
في كاريزما مع الموهبه هو في حضور مع
الموهبه هو في تقبل للجمهور ولكن هناك
ايضا اشخاص كانوا هم ممثل سعودي يعني
الذاكره مش مش سامحين ان انا اذكر اسامي
حاجه ولكن عمل على نفسه واشتغل على نفسه
وتوقفه قدام الكاميرا في الكوميديا
فالاصبح ناجح في الخط الكوميدي فبالتالي
رجوعا الى نفس الموضوع الموهبه وحدها لا
تكفي ولابد من ثقل الموهبه بالعمل ولابد
من ثقل الموهبه بان انت تعمل تصميم لخطه
معينه تقدر توصلك للهدف حتى لا تحرق
موهبتك او حتى
ممكن ههه انا مش هحرق اي حاجه لا موهبه
ولا عمل زاد شكرا جزيلا لك مدربه
والمهارات
معنا من القاهره شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات